you got to do this yeah I am doing it
from here it's not gonna jump it your
promise yeah I promise it won't cuz I
ain't gonna touch it Nick tell him how I
feel I just did this you did the Frog
everybody does the Frog
Kevin series is supposed to be about
working out and when guests Nick
challenges cab to hold an emperor
scorpion hearts heart rate really gets
going
just hold Nick so if you don't hold this
thing you gotta make sure you're gonna
have to hold the next one I got promised
do anything I promised to be taller next
year doesn't mean it's gonna happen
that is a large snake come on black
people leave white people all the time
this is nothing new
Kevin yeah we could have told you Kev's
not exactly an animal guy and forget
going on Fallon with Steve Irwin's son
this is Gisele all right Kevin this is
Roy
what animals don't you like I don't like
any of like any what Kevin does like
stay fit while keeping fans entertained
and the tick-tocking expected dad has
really had to amp that up in season
three very hard because everything has
been done show ways to be active fires
[Music]